- "GEICO ordered to pay
Missouri woman 5.2 million
after she contracted STD in car."
"GEICO must pay 5.2 million
to a woman who got HPV
from sex in man's insured
car, court rules."
Well, I'm sorry to tell you
that the headlines are wrong,
but the truth is even more interesting
because it involves nuances
and esoteric details of insurance law.
Now, you may have heard
that GEICO was on the hook for 5 million
because a woman contracted HPV
after she had sex with a man
in his 2014 Hyundai Genesis
that was insured by GEICO.
And it is true that a thing happened
that a lawsuit was filed
between the former couple.
The man knew he apparently
had throat cancer
that was caused by HPV
but did not tell the woman that he had it.
She took him to an arbitration
and was awarded more than 5 million.
As Lawyer Elie Mystal put it,
"That was probably an expensive
15 minutes for GEICO."
(dramatic music)
Now, it occurs to me
that I probably should have
put a warning on this episode.
If there are any kids watching,
sex is when two people love each other
and then wrestle in the back of a car,
in this case, a 2014 Hyundai Genesis.
And when those two people
no longer love each other,
they will sue each other for
what happened in that car.
Now, how does that implicate
GEICO, you might ask?
Well, the man's car was insured by GEICO.
The encounter happened in 2017,
and the woman filed an insurance
claim, which GEICO denied.
GEICO told the woman
it's auto insurance coverage didn't apply
because the damages claim did not arise
out of a normal use of the vehicle,
which I think we can all
agree, probably makes sense.
And now to understand this whole case,
we have to take our first diversion
into the nuances of insurance law.
Because generally speaking,
when you get an insurance policy,
it provides insurance over,
let's say an accident happening,
in occurrence of some
kind, but in addition,
you'll often get what's
called a duty to defend.
In other words, if you are sued
over something that might
be covered by the policy,
then the insurance company
has to provide lawyers
or at least the funds for
lawyers to defend that case.
♪ Send lawyers, guns and money ♪
Now, when an insurance company refuses
to defend its policy holder,
it's considered basically the same
as denying coverage outright,
saying that the policy doesn't cover
the accident that happened.
So an insurance company
that wrongfully refuses
to defend its insured can be liable
for the cost of the defense
in any damages that arise
from the breach of their duty to defend.
Now, how do you know
if a policy is going to
apply to an accident,
or whether the insurance company
has a duty to defend you?
Well, you look to the four corners
of the complaint in the lawsuit,
and you compare that to the policy itself.
This is called the four corners rule,
or sometimes the eight corners.
You're comparing what's contained
inside the lawsuit complaint
to what's contained inside the policy.
And if it's possible, if
it's a remote possibility
that this claim could be
covered by the insurance policy,
then the insurance company
has to provide you with a defense.
Now, if the allegations are untrue,
then the insurance company
won't have to pay a judgment
because well, they'll win.
But you can't know that
until the trial is over,
which is why the insured
needs someone to pay
for their defense.
And that's why there's
often a duty to defend
under certain policies.
And that's why sometimes the defense costs
are the whole ballgame.
If the insurance company
denies the defense,
then the insured might
be in a world of trouble.
They have to defend against
a lawsuit all on their own,
and lawyers are expensive.
Now, an old partner of
mine used to say that,
"The only thing an
insurance policy gets you
is the right to sue an insurance company."
In other words, if they deny
your defense or deny coverage,
then you might have to
sue the insurance company
if you lose the initial
case going forward.
But that's why some plaintiff's attorneys
will actually specifically
try to cast their allegations
in a way that will invoke
insurance coverage,
so that they make sure
the insurance company
is part of the litigation.
They'll either add another claim,
or they will craft the story
of what happened in a way that might fall
under coverage of the insurance company
because the insurance companies
tend to be the ones that
have the big pockets.
So now we come back to
this particular case.
In February of 2021, the woman sent GEICO
a copy of a lawsuit that
she was about to file
against the Insured,
the guy that she had sex with in the car.
She offered to settle
the claim for $1 million.
GEICO ignored the notice.
Basically, GEICO decided
that the claim wasn't covered
and refused to defend.
Basically, GEICO said, "Having
sex in a car that we ensure
is not covered under the policy,
so we're not going to provide coverage,
and we're not going to provide a defense
to the guy whose car it was."
And for the record,
these people only use their
initials in the lawsuit,
which was probably an
incredibly smart decision
so that they don't go and down in history
for something that may
or may not have happened
in this particular suit.
And for the record, M.O.
is the injured party.
She's the one that contracted HPV.
M.B. is the man with a
car who gave her HPV.
So now we're in 2021,
M.B. is going to defend
this lawsuit on his own dime
because GEICO has refused
to provide a defense.
So GEICO basically takes
itself out of the picture.
At which point, the Insured, M.B.,
the guy with the car and the STI,
enter into an arbitration agreement
with M.O. in March of 2021.
And they agree to settle their
dispute through arbitration.
Now, Missouri's insurance laws
have some procedural quirks,
and the relevant statute
is section 537.065.
That statute allows a claimant, like M.O.,
to enter into a contract
with the tort-feasor here,
M.B., the guy with the HPV,
to settle their dispute
in private arbitration,
which would be much, much cheaper
and much, much quicker than
going to trial in state court.
Now, you're allowed to enter
into one of these agreements
when the insurance company has
refused to defend the insured
or agrees to a defense of honor
under a reservation of rights,
which I won't go into.
Now, the parties enter
arbitration with an agreement
that the maximum payout
that the arbitrator can give
is whatever the insurance
policy limits are.
And generally, that the plaintiff
won't go after the
defendant, the tort-feasor,
and will just take the judgment
and use it against the insurance company,
which as discussed, depends
on whether the claim
is covered or not.
Effectively, the plaintiff is gambling
that the claim is or
should have been covered.
And if they win in arbitration,
they're going to take that award and say,
"You, insurance company,
you should have covered your insured.
And, therefore, you can just
pay me everything that was owed
because we made this side agreement."
So in other words, once you
get an award in arbitration,
either the insured sues
the insurance company
and turns that money over to the claimant,
or the claimant standing
in the shoes of the insured
sues the insurance company saying
that they wrongfully denied
coverage or defense costs,
that's called subrogation.
Now, obviously, insurance
companies hated all of this
and that's why this section
has been amended twice,
once in 2017 and once in 2021.
And this is effectively
exactly what happened here.
They went to arbitration without GEICO,
'cause GEICO said they
didn't wanna participate,
they didn't think it was covered,
and the claimant got an
award of $5.2 million.
And the arbitrator found,
and yes, this is the actual language
that the arbitrator had to find
because law is interesting.
The arbitrator found, quote,
"there was sexual activity
in Insured's automobile in
November/December of 2017
which occurred in Jackson
County, Missouri; 2,
these sexual activity in Insured's vehicle
'directly caused, or directly contributed
to M.O. to be infected with HPV';
3, Insured knew or had
been told his throat cancer
was diagnosed as HPV positive;
4, Insured should have
disclosed his diagnosis
to M.O. prior to their sexual
activity that occurred,
and he did not; and 5,
Insured was negligent and is liable
for causing M.O. to contract HPV.
The arbitrator found that
the 'amount that would fairly
and justly compensate Plaintiff, M.O.,
for all of her damages and
injuries is $5.2 million'
and entered an award in that amount
'in favor of Plaintiff, M.O.,
and against the Defendant, the Insured.'"
So in the end,
the arbitrator awarded her
5.2 million in damages.
And so the headlines were sort of right,
that M.O. did get a
judgment for 5.2 million
against the guy that screwed her.
Pun absolutely intended.
(bomb exploding)
But here, it just wasn't against GEICO.
Yet, GEICO asserted that
the plaintiff and defendant
had conspired to jack up the damages award
in the arbitration.
M.O.'s counsel says that
this wasn't the situation
in their case, that the liability
and damages were determined on the merits,
and the arbitration
proceeding was not based
on any admissions and that
it was fairly contested.
There were arguments and
witnesses going both ways.
But after this arbitration award,
the woman informed the
Insured that she would file
an action in state court to
confirm the damages award,
which is what you do.
When you get an arbitration award,
you then basically
confirm it in state court.
Now, at this point,
GEICO tried to intervene.
They wanted a new trial
because they didn't think
the arbitration was fair.
That motion was denied.
But at the same time, in April of 2021,
GEICO filed a separate
suit in federal court
in the district of Kansas
seeking a determination
that it has no duty to defend
or indemnify M.B., the guy with HPV.
So GEICO chose to fight
its case in two fronts,
one in the state court
and one in federal court.
And it's really the federal court case
that's going to determine on the merits,
whether GEICO actually
has to provide a defense
or provide indemnity based
on the contract language.
We'll come back to that in a second.
Now, in state court, GEICO
argued that the judgment,
the arbitration, violated the
company's due process rights,
and the arbitration
agreement was unenforceable.
GEICO said it never had an
opportunity to participate
in discovery or to provide
a meaningful defense.
And by the time that they
were aware of the judgment,
they argued it was too late.
And you can see some merit to this.
They didn't get a chance
to contest the facts
in this more or less secret arbitration,
where the Claimant and the
Insured might have colluded
to drive up the award.
And at the very least,
the Insured didn't care
because, by virtue of the
agreement that he made,
he wasn't on the hook for the damages.
So he might not have colluded,
but he also didn't care if
there was this giant judgment
because the Plaintiff, M.O.,
was just gonna turn around
and sue GEICO over it.
Now, on the other hand, this
arbitration and this award,
it's not against GEICO,
it's an award against M.B., the HPV guy.
If GEICO was right that the
policy doesn't cover it,
then they don't have to pay.
And we'll talk about that in a second,
whether the policy covers it.
And if GEICO wanted to participate
in this from the very beginning
and they were worried that they
would have to pay indemnity
to M.B. or cover his defense costs,
then they could have
provided him a defense
from the very beginning.
That's the point of the duty to defend.
And that's why state
laws are often crafted
in a way to incentivize
insurance companies
to provide a defense.
Because you can't go back in time
and provide a defense after the fact.
So if you, the insurance
company, are worried
that you might have to
cover the damages award,
well, then provide a defense to the guy
that you provided insurance
and participate throughout
the entire thing.
As the Missouri court found, quote,
"GEICO's claim of
constitutional deprivations
presumes GEICO was denied the opportunity
to defend its interest relating
to M.O.'s claims against Insured,
including the ability to
challenge liability and damages.
But GEICO did have the
opportunity to participate
and defend its interests,
including the ability to
challenge liability and damages,
by entering a defense of the Insured.
GEICO did not take advantage
of this opportunity,
and instead denied coverage
and refused to defend Insured.
Moreover, GEICO initiated a
declaratory judgment action
in federal court seeking a determination
as to its obligations
under the insurance policy,
and that federal action
provides yet another forum
in which GEICO may defend its interest."
And right, the federal court action.
GEICO is currently suing in federal court
for an order that says
the policy doesn't cover
the HPV transmission at all.
And if they win, they
won't have to pay anything,
no part of the 5.2 million,
because that judgment is only against M.B.
So the headlines were wrong.
There has been no determination
that GEICO was responsible
for this 5.2 million award, for now.
There's also no determination
that GEICO wrongfully
denied a defense to M.B.,
but they might.
Now, usually if someone
files an insurance claim
because they were injured in a car,
it's because of an accident.
That's one of the reasons that this seems
like an unfair ruling.
It puts insurance companies
in a weird position
of defending any and all claims,
no matter how bonkers they might seem.
But it's really a question
of whether the insurance
policy actually applies
to this scenario.
GEICO asserted that there's no way policy
can be interpreted to include
this kind of negligence.
The woman sued over the
contracting an STI in a car.
But to determine that,
we have to look at the policy language.
Generally, since insurance
companies write these policies,
the language is construed against them.
Let me know if you've ever had a chance
to write a custom insurance endorsement.
Generally, the insurance company
gives you what they give you,
which is why policies are
often hundreds of pages long.
They're trying to prevent
any and all weird situation.
So in this particular case,
what does the policy say?
Well, I had to do some digging,
but I found the relevant language
in GEICO's appellate brief.
According to GEICO, the
policy covers bodily injuries
"arising out of the ownership,
operation, maintenance
or use of a motor vehicle."
Now, you might notice, that
language is very broad.
Does this type of injury arise
out of the ownership of a car?
Well, it seems like a lot
of stuff arises out of the ownership.
Does it qualify as use of
the motor vehicle? Maybe.
Is this a bodily injury? Maybe.
Is it the type of bodily injury
that's intended to be covered
by an insurance policy?
Who knows?
But for the most part, you're just looking
at the text and the meaning of the words
that are in the policy itself
construed against the insurance company
or in the light that is more
favorable to the insured.
So it's possible that GEICO
might have to cover this,
because if it's even possible
that this language covers this situation,
then GEICO was wrong to deny
defense to M.B., the Insured,
and they're gonna be on the hook
for not only the attorney's fees,
but also the award of damages itself.
But we'll know soon.
GEICO filed a lawsuit in federal court
seeking a declaratory judgment
that it is not responsible
for this situation.
And that is scheduled
for trial in October.
But even if GEICO loses,
don't consider this a license
to engage in unsafe sex,
because you can bet
that GEICO has already
changed the policy language
in all of its car policies to make sure
that no future policies cover
this situation in the future.
But either way,
it seems this is the new
McDonald's hot coffee case.
People completely misunderstood
what was happening
in this particular case.
But it is another example
of using your car for weird things.
But really, people,
instead of using your car,
since we're all working from home,
you should upgrade your decoration.
I recently upgraded my office
with the help of today's
sponsor, Displate.
Displate sells high
quality metal art prints
that couldn't be easier to install.
I've been using Displate
literally for years,
even before they were a sponsor.
Here, let me show you.
Here's the one I've had for
years, easy to switch out.
Boom. Adjust it.
Looks good.
Displate is great because
you never have to deal
with a cheap looking plastic frame
or trying to make sure
it's perfectly straight.
Because you can hang
them up using magnets,
installation is a breeze,
and you can easily swap them
out with whatever you want.
There are no nails and no holes,
you can adjust it or
replace it however you want.
Displate has millions of
designs ranging for movies,
vintage posters, maps, art music, nature,
and the list goes on and on.
I actually chose a bunch
of inside legal jokes.
Here's a patent application for a gavel.
But whether you are a law nerd like me,
you will find something that you love,
that you wanna display every single day.
And this month, Displate
is offering a summer sale
where if you purchase
using the link below,
you'll get 25% off one or two Displates
and a whopping 29% off three or more.
And it's automatically applied
to your cart at checkout.
So click on the link in the description
or the link that's on screen right now
to automatically get a huge discount
on whatever Displate that you want
and revamp your home or office.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it, click
on this playlist over here
with all of my other legal videos.
So click on this link,
or I'll see you in court.